Film Courage: When I look back at some of
the Danny Elfman videos did you help direct
any of those?
Richard Elfman (Filmmaker of FORBIDDEN ZONE):
Yes, I’ve helped produced some, directed
one (PRIVATE LIFE) although it was Danny’s
conception.
He knows very much what he wants in the videos.
Film Courage: They are very creative.
And do you see a correlation…or not a correlation
but a difference in music videos from the
80’s and 90’s compared to now?
In terms of the production value wasn’t
there as much but the story was.
Richard: Well a story is very important in
a musical number or a video.
Great videos have a beginning, middle and
end (so do great musical numbers) going back
to CHICAGO which had great serviceable music
but it had beautifully choreographed dance
numbers that had a beginning, middle and end.
Extraordinary, extraordinary.
Okay MOULIN ROUGE! unfortunately what they
did was they shot tons of footage for the
musical numbers and then just shot, shot,
shot, shot, shot.
No beginning, middle and end.
You are bored by the end of the musical number.
No story, just a bunch of images.
Film Courage: What did you think of BIRDMAN?
Richard: I liked it and I’m a huge Michael
Keaton fan.
Well I loved him as BATMAN.
And I want to see him come back for BEETLEJUICE,
they are talking about doing another BEETLEJUICE.
Film Courage: He was great in THE FOUNDER
too (I don’t know if you saw that)?
About the McDonald’s founder Ray Kroc?
Richard: I did not see that.
Film Courage: But when you look at BIRDMAN,
is there anything about his character that
strikes you?
Richard: Well it’s a very different…he’s
one of those actors who can just do anything.
It was just an iconic role, not like anything
he has done.
Film Courage: But in terms of…you’ve been
a film director, a theater director was there
something that got you about the film because
it was not the most happiest of endings?
Richard: To put it mildly.
Film Courage: Without any spoilers but was
there a part that you really resonated with?
Richard: I enjoyed the film but it wasn’t
earthshaking for me.
But I loved the film.
I have other films that are my top 10, my
top 20.
Film Courage: Oh!
Top Ten, I’d love to hear them.
Richard: Gosh in a nutshell?
Okay, Hitchcock’s PSYCHO, Scorsese’s CASINO,
what’s the one with RAGING BULL, Coen Brothers
Oh Brother Where Art Thou?, David Lynch BLUE
VELVET, Coppola GODFATHER I and II…you know
the classics.
Film Courage: With Hitchcock I was watching
a documentary and they were talking about
how some of his sort of sexual repression
was able to show…
Richard: It sure did in PSYCHO!
Film Courage: Right…so what could be a hindrance
to some people actually on screen (who knows
what some of the stories were on set) but
that it really translated into amazing performances.
Just want to hear your take on it since you
seem very open.
Richard: I wouldn’t describe myself as repressed!
And that’s the thing like how crazy or neurotic
does an artist have to be and how does it
translate through the work?
I don’t believe you have to be crazy or
neurotic as an artist.
You can learn it in some method acting classes.
I’ve learned tricks to make actors cry.
Film Courage: They [the documentary] talked
about how he didn’t feel comfortable in
his own body and that maybe he even used his
weight as a way to kind of keep people away
from him but then there was something about
that which translated on screen because…
Richard: I can relate to that because I need
to lose 10 pounds if I want to get into this
senior boxing division next year [Richard
is a former boxer].
Film Courage: Well I don’t think you need
to lose weight and I wasn’t going there
but I’m just talking about.
Richard: I’m just kidding.
He was a master and it’s hard to get into
someone’s head and to me that was the ultimate
explosion of sexual repression.
It was like a perfect film…Oh!
THE THIRD MAN is one on the top of my list.
That I can watch over and over and over.
Film Courage: Do you think there are people
like Orson Welles still in this town today?
Sort of this charismatic…I mean there are
so many charismatic people but…
Richard: Here is what is going to get me into
trouble, CITIZEN KANE to me is the most overrated
film of all time.
Film Courage: Okay?
Richard: Brilliant cinematography.
I forgot the guy’s name but he actually
shared his director credit with the cinematographer.
Film Courage: Not Elia Kazan but…?
Richard: No but Elia Kazan is one of my favorite
directors but getting back to CITIZEN KANE
so okay he takes this brilliant cinematographer
and gives him free reign and does innovative
shots, innovative eating and has a really,
really interesting film.
I have a simple test with film being great
or comedy being funny.
The film being great is how easy is it for
you to turn it off?
It is that simple, no rocket science.
We’ve all got films that we don’t want
to turn off.
We’re late for the appointment and we want
to keep watching.
Those are our greatest films.
I’ve never had trouble turning off CITIZEN
KANE.
I can’t turn off GODFATHER I or II, I can’t
turn off Scorsese’s greatest films I just
want to keep watching.
I don’t know about you guys but it just
doesn’t hold me?
I love the shots, I love the editing, there
is genius going on but I have no trouble turning
it off.
So it’s not on my top 10 or top 20.
Film Courage: How do you feel about TAXI DRIVER?
Richard: Top 20.
Sorry about that, RAGING BULL, TAXI DRIVER,
my gosh!
So brilliant.
And then with modern films I liked WONDER
WOMAN, BLACK PANTHER, and Tim Burton BEETLEJUICE,
EDWARD SCISSOR HANDS and some of my brother’s
greatest work [Danny Elfman] has been for
Tim Burton.
So these are all on my list.
Film Courage: What would you say the difference
is between film directors let’s say in the
age of Hitchcock, maybe Scorsese, Coppola
so we are spanning a few decades there compared
to now?
What’s the difference?
Is it just the roles that they have to play
by in terms of there is such pressure…
Richard: I mean every generation has brilliant
filmmakers and a lot of junk that time sorts
it out, time sorts it out.
Film Courage: That’s true because we’re
not really hearing about the ones that fell
by the wayside back then even though it were
less filmmakers.
Richard: Right, we remember Elia Kazan’s
ON THE WATERFRONT or A STREET CAR NAMED DESIRE.
We think of those but we don’t think about
all the junk that happened in the 1950’s.